sponsored by step finance your go to d5
portfolio manager on solana luno if
you're just getting into bitcoin it's
the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh
punch show we have another really
exciting episode today talking all about
bitcoin as always this show is powered
by the bc firm icon plus capital and it
is sponsored by block fi if you're
interested in um joining block five you
can get around 200 i think they offer
really amazing interest rates much
better than what you're getting um in
the fiat system right now so let's jump
into this um discussion today joining me
is congressman pete sessions from the
17th congressional district of texas
let's welcome congressman sessions to
the show how are you doing
i'm good i made it thank you very much
what an interesting
time that we live in and especially for
bitcoin
yeah absolutely it's so fascinating to
see um more and more politicians people
from the traditional system getting
involved
and really just you know sharing their
um their support for bitcoin so i want
to go through all of this with you but
before we do um you mentioned it is an
interesting time and it certainly is an
interesting time so politically things
are a little bit polarized i'd say more
so than ever um i want to just sort of
get your thoughts in the general
situation you know from racism to covert
to vaccines to now impending wars
there's just so much polarization so i'd
like to get your thoughts
on the current political landscape in
the u.s particularly when it comes to
the federal government
well the federal government is engaged
in an experiment that they
failed to at least the majority party
failed to let people know
what they would be doing and we had a
clear idea about donald trump
economically
more people were working in the history
of the country
more revenue was coming into the federal
government we were
working to
finish off the wall
in on the southern border
our military was
moving uh towards a different direction
we had taking care of the problem in
korea north korea things were generally
but good but i will tell you that donald
trump loves a fight
and so he had a fight with the american
people and
we now see that we have a president
who
despite his previous
29 or 30 years in the united states
senate he has
done a reverse course
from what had been his past and
from the day that he
began the campaign he was very cautious
and quiet did not give a lot of answers
day one he was in the white house he
started on a different pathway that
pathway
which has created the further division
this in this country is uh based on
inflation and availability of jobs and
covet and rules and regulations so i am
engaged in
as a member of
congress a lot of debate that takes
place about rule of law
uh the border uh people coming here
afghanistan i mean if you're if you're a
policy guy
you've got a lot of stuff on your plate
and and the bottom line is is that what
brings us
to bitcoin which i think is a fair once
again my analysis
uh bitcoin has become very popular
because we're trying to turn the dollar
into something that is less than
than something that would be strong and
stable and and be prepared for the
future so
many young people have looked up in the
last couple years now i know bitcoin you
know a lot of money was made
10 years ago moving forward but
increasingly the popularity is
that
people who are younger than i am
between you and me
uh in our ages they want to be able to
know that the work that they do and the
money that they save and the stability
of financial transactions
is in their own personal best interest
and that's what the blockchain is
that's what cryptocurrency represents
that's what bitcoin is
it is a an opportunity for you to invest
for you to have this
safety and the security
of the of the transactions that will
take place that you can control
much of it your own destiny and so uh
i've got a 35 year old son who's a
medical doctor
uh he wants to be successful in life 15
20 30 years from now
i have uh
at my age i've lived off the stock
market i've lived with investment
and people who are younger need that
same opportunity last
lastly the bottom line is
the stability of the currency in a world
market
is coming increasingly under pressure
and that world market means that there
are others that want to overtake the
dollar they do not want the dollar to be
the dominant uh currency
and so this new bitcoin this new
cryptocurrency this new way to look at
life
is uh is one chain across the whole
world
and very interesting i think has a
bright future i
as a member of congress want people to
know
that we need to study and understand
this as members of congress i sit on the
house financial services committee
uh
one of the senior members of that
committee i get in the debates i see
uh what the fed is doing to the dollar i
want to see
what regulation would do what is proper
regulation how should we
look at uh cryptocurrency
and to make sure that america and
americans
become world leaders
and the stability of the united states
right with that so that it makes america
look good we like all the money in the
world to flow to the united states but
i'd say texas
uh and the last part is uh that uh riot
blockchain
is uh owns a the largest bit mining
bitcoin mining operation in north
america
just about
60 miles south and east of waco texas
where i sit right now so
a lot of interesting things not just
about
blockchain and bitcoin but about
cryptocurrency uh from the high side
so clearly um a lot of appreciation for
the industry which i like and you
mentioned a lot of things that like
education and regulation
inflation and you know the the issue
with the dollar and we're going to get
into all of that but before we do um
something which is particularly
interesting about texas which i'd love
to get your take on is the exodus that
we're seeing from these democrat states
like california like new york um i think
even elon musk made that comment that
you know he's moving down i think he's
already moved down to texas i think it's
tesla um that moved their headquarters
down to texas so
um why do you think there's this massive
exodus to these more conservative
republican states like florida and like
texas and also
what does that then mean um
for i guess the landscape in the u.s do
you have any concerns
about this exodus towards texas
well the
the concern is is maybe uh misplaced
uh and i and i do want to address that
uh we you've had the the the problems
are in california and these other states
california's lost 151
billionaires
of of recent
and many of them have moved to either
colorado
arizona uh
las vegas nevada or to texas and florida
they have sought these places at least
to texas and florida
from a perspective of their less tax
states they do not want to take
you know a death tax they don't want to
take your money california chases people
down five years after they have left
they're after desperately money and is
because they have an insatiable appetite
from
their
government to give things away
to
create uh
problems
uh out of other people's wealth and it's
easy to spend money that is not yours
when it's your money and you're trying
to be judicious and careful and balanced
about it you tend to be a little bit i'm
going to use your term more conservative
well yeah we do and i i think that is
true but we're also not here to take
your money so it's a freedom issue and
freedom is just as important as any of
these terms
as opposed to conservative freedom means
that you will have a chance to come
and make your own mark to make your own
money
we want you to take care of communities
and organizations and other people we're
not like we
don't care
but it's yours it's a fundamentally a
freedom issue
and then i find that the people who are
engaged in in the last
three weeks i've spent a good bit of
time at bitcoin
type uh conferences and meetings
very benevolent people people who care
very deeply not only about others
but about the future and so i i would
not offer nothing but accolades
for the type of social
responsibility
caring about others i have a down
syndrome son
i care about disabled people i care
about people who cannot take care of
themselves but that doesn't mean that we
give away
the
necessarily the riches or the savings or
the opportunity from other people but
rather to build them into
uh the
the the the enterprise system that we
believe in and and i think that's
that's a great thing so fear no freedom
yes
i agree with you on that freedom
absolutely i'm actually from london and
i'm i'm moving to miami for freedom
purposes so there you go it was either
that or
central texas i could not tell for sure
with that accent
yeah yeah definitely definitely having
to move to miami but let's go into
bitcoin um because you know you
obviously shed a lot of appreciation for
it um i want to understand firstly
actually how you first came across it
and what your initial thoughts were
the uh initial thoughts that i have go
back uh easily ten years where i began
talking about it and people looked at me
with strange tones
and strange looks
and of course as you know
some of the people that were the first
into the business
have done very well
but i think that over time the stability
and the growth factor and the
opportunity
for people to own
and keep what is theirs they don't mind
paying taxes well
they know they have to
but but they they want to make sure that
it's not
uh
given away
and democrats
uh and this is just the fact our our
democrat our democrats love to spend
money your money
they love to take away your freedoms
and they're a very expensive group of
people they have been expensive ever
since i've known them my whole life
they like to take other people's money
and then throw
epithets at you
about you to to take advantage of you
what we need is an opportunity and so i
came across this to pay attention to pay
attention and listen and see
uh it has led me not only here in mileum
county texas rockdale texas maybe a term
that you know
uh where the largest bitcoin mining
operation is in north america
but also to the attributes of the
blockchain the attributes of this new
technology the attributes of
confidence that young people have that
they
want a bright future also
and so every bit of that has piqued my
interest
and i want us to be successful as i've
said
i would like
um anybody that wants to
have their business or job here in
america will take that money and do
great things with it
you mentioned that democrats like to
spend other people's money and i
understand that um and ted cruz actually
made a speech um a couple of months ago
saying how um politicizing bitcoin
saying that the left don't like it
because they can't control it now this
had two reactions within the community
the first reaction was wow you know we
have this senator um you know talking
about bitcoin that's amazing however the
second reaction was that they didn't
appreciate that it was being politicized
um and there's a there's a comment and a
narrative that bitcoin is in fact
apolitical so i'd like to get your take
on that do you think bitcoin um is a
political and
with that in mind do you think it's
going to eventually become a partisan
issue
these are all very interesting questions
and in fact i have seen as you suggest
crowds of people i've been in houston
i've been in miami
i have seen people who probably are a
political who also don't want it
politicized
just as much as i would say
the socialist in the crowd
but the the
unavoidable facts of the case the
factors and facts are
that the democratic party wants
the money
they want to take what is there which
means that they want to invest time into
rules and regulations
that will create barriers
and hurdles
for them that will make it harder for
the investor to
put the money in to make money and to
take it out
uh and right now there is uh an
opportunity in washington d.c
as we look at what we're doing
and you can kind of see the facts and
factors as they play i without regard to
politics
treasury department does not want anyone
to be able to get an ira
off of their uh
what might be bitcoin
bitcoin if it's going to take off again
needs more people who will buy into the
system
and right now
some of our larger brokerage firms and
some of these other
political
entities that are called democrats
they tend to err on the side of them
other issues that are germane
but that may or may not be truthful and
one of them is the energy industry
and you have seen where sierra club
in their calculations have stated that
uh it will be bitcoin uh it will be
mining it will be cryptocurrency
because the mining operations that would
use excess
excessive amounts
of energy electrical energy well there's
some balance to that because a good
number of people who are now in the
bitcoin industry are getting into green
energy
they're trying to
feed what might be the grid system with
green electricity
that came comes directly from
their money that they invested to be a
part of it so
i think that there are some things that
are
givens that
our friends that are democrats do want
to pay for the government they want to
take other people's money
but we're trying to keep it into a
territory
uh that is as you suggest a political
yeah i think you're right it is this
it's going to be an inevitable politic
politicization if i can put it that way
of bitcoin unfortunately despite the
technology being a political um
naturally that's gonna happen when it
comes down to um you know empowering
people to take ownership over their over
their freedom and their assets you
mentioned um regulation there and um you
know we've seen a lot of hostility um
from the the government when it comes to
bitcoin um so the question is
what is the concern that america gets
left behind when it comes to this
innovation i say this today actually
particularly because australia have
confirmed the bitcoin um spot etf but
america still doesn't have one canada
has one but america still doesn't have
one so what are the dangers of america
being left behind and how likely is that
well i think i think left behind is
perhaps a an appropriate term but i
think what what might be
uh really a way to look at it is
we would be delayed or we would
miss the market entry
the uh entrepreneur is the person we
typically
have these sayings in the free
enterprise system about ipos initial
product offering an ipo in many ipos in
our history some fail
but a good number also make a good bit
of money because their value then became
becomes seen
uh by the public uh and universally then
the the
power related to their proximity to
making money
rises the the the amount of wealth and
so i think it's important that ideas
like ipos
uh
be owned by americans that we put our
entrepreneurial hat on am i opposed to
england no
do i want to see england make it heck
yes especially
given their recent history would need to
be in an economy that is growing and
strong
but
not being british
i don't want to tell the british what to
do but i do want to tell americans we
need to be smart we need to use our
entrepreneurial uh
ability that we have we need to create
the goods and services we need to be
able to create the best ideas
and that is what i want america to
achieve
in this whole effort and then i want the
government not to crush it you know
they're good at killing the killing the
baby in the in the crib
and uh we had this same issue as we
dealt with the internet how were we
going to do it where are we going to tax
the internet
and at some point it became big enough
where we said okay
it can stand on its own two feet
and america has prospered but so has the
system and that's where
the knowledge of the free enterprise
system the knowledge of this
uh bitcoin
uh blockchain
uh the opportunity we need to own that
because there are many many many
opportunities behind that
for people
to enrich themself and our great nation
yeah you make an interesting point
actually about england um obviously i'm
from there and their lack of um
innovation when it comes to crypto um
compared to miami's innovation um
because they obviously have a mayor
who's really um you know pushing forward
with bitcoin and miami coin and all
these sorts of things is what drove me
here um so you know i'm now adding value
to this economy rather than the london
economy
right
among other things
many other things um freedom and many
other things but you know just on a
small scale that's it simply playing out
so if places refuse to innovate the
innovators will leave um and so i yeah i
agree with you you know that's that's
one of the major concerns i mean i think
the thing you bring is excitement and
opportunity uh to our shore
and uh the confidence we need confidence
that uh
it's just like the way i think about the
future there are a lot of people that
are worried about the future and i am
very robust i think number one there's
no problem that we can't solve and
number two i want to run at the future
knowing we've got good answers and good
answers come from smart people i like to
say i'm not trying to be this way so
much but
texans have the answers and i think
texas
well we do we we look why why do why are
people
fleeing to texas there you go why are
they coming here well it's not because
we got bad ideas it's because we've been
able to
harness that opportunity with the the
affection that you spoke about so i i
look i understand why you're going to
miami as opposed to waco texas i get
that
uh but but we've got to say hi
and well there you go and florida has it
i mean ron desantis as as the
young governor uh has really stepped up
and of course the the mayor uh there in
miami wants miami to be the the bitcoin
capital of the world
uh good for them i like it i've sent
some uh some healthy some healthy state
competition
that i can expect well there's sort of
one competition as you think there is
but we'll let you live there and we'll
let you enjoy it
great beach there
absolutely you mentioned um at the
beginning of the conversation about the
um the lack of stability right now um
with the dollar so i'd like to just go
into
what are the biggest problems facing the
us dollar right now
well the biggest problem is inflation
the biggest problem is excessive
government spending
and the bottom line which is undeniable
and is that
our friends the democrats have made
friends with
the things that create push and add to
inflation and and that's their go-to guy
that is what they have chosen
uh overwhelmingly to do and they're not
wanting to back off that when you do
things
that create circumstances to where
either you put money in that somebody
else's money or you borrow money to make
up for your own deficiencies you are
going to then get away from that market
that ability so in this case
uh there's a guy named joe biden sleepy
joe
the president gets into office and
immediately goes to
his fed
chairman his treasury chairman
janet yellen
and they put a demand on
for the federal government to begin
issuing
loans bonds for a hundred and ten
billion dollars a month
and what that does is it does at least
two things that have created the third
and number one it it
changes uh who's paying money in and it
became the federal government the
federal government took that lead in
authority and responsibility but you've
got to pay it back
and so by taking out these loans
it means that our debt load is increased
greatly so if you think of america's
green our
fed
as like a great big bucket of green
paint green for money
value
investment
opportunity savings
and and then you pour a bunch of loans
into it
let's be like throwing a different color
paint in i don't know what is white or
purple it changes the green to a
different color
and that is what they're doing they and
we call that devaluation of the dollar
so what is happening is is that in order
to float our boat
to meet the political considerations
that our friends the democrats wanted
they didn't want people to go to work
even today even today
let's call this we'll act like today is
4 15 i know where a day or two past that
but
april 15th even april 15th the office of
personnel management
out of the white house has not given
instructions for federal employees and
agencies to get people back to work
if you look at their faq
frequently asked questions
the questions and answers all come from
a year and a half ago when president
trump was in office
and i assume there is some relationship
here these cats don't even under biden
don't even want to come to work
themselves
they want to don't want to do work and
yet they want
to be paid
and our economy
which we are a capitalist nation
i hope
the economy has to have people that go
to work that pay taxes that move our
economy and democrats once again they're
very expensive the group of people that
are very expensive they're very snobbish
they want to take your money
out of your pocket out of your future
out of your opportunity and had you pay
it to your favorite uncle
and so what's happened is is that uncle
sam now
has taken this money
and borrowed it but we have to pay it
back so
the the biggest problem that we've got
is inflation now
it's also
that democrats want people to stay at
home they want teachers not to be in the
classroom without our teachers in the
classroom parents cannot go to work you
can't schedule yourself we have
blockchain issues literally i'm going to
use that term in the free enterprise
system right now where people cannot
aren't going to work and so
huge
just in time delivery systems whether it
be pipes or hoses or
cars or food
all these things are being put in a way
that is delayed so there is a scarcity
of
of assets and resources out there
when there's a scarcity but people still
need it the highest bidder
then pays the most for it and that is
what has caused inflation to go up so
once again perfect storm for the
democrats and president biden
but like anything else get ready because
november is the election and republicans
are going to be able to i think sell
properly to the american people of what
is happening this is a grab for not just
their wallet
this is a grab for
changing america the way we look
and they want us to be socialist and
about half those cats wants to be they
want us to be a communist nation i still
love to say to him please show me where
it works better in the united states
and their argument is very plainly well
it doesn't work very well well it may
not work very well but it works better
than anywhere else
and i'm proud to be
not only
a texan i'm proud to be for the free
enterprise system i'm a capitalist
yeah i definitely agree with you that um
at this rate america is going
is going down a more socialist path i
mean i've had some conversations with um
business owners down here in miami and
um people are saying that they just
can't get people back to work um and
they had that issue mainly during the
pandemic because people were literally
getting paid to stay at home um and so
exactly right the federal government is
taking money and taking a loan out for
it and telling people ah don't worry
about it
there's there's going to be heck to pl
to pay and that heck
is what is a it's it's a technical term
but
it it is uh
a recession
yeah
and um you mentioned the election in
november you previously uh previously
tweeted um that bitcoin is aligned with
american values so what are these
american values um that you think
bitcoin is aligned with and obviously
how do you see that alignment
well very plainly the most obvious thing
is is that we want people to have
freedom and opportunity and to plan for
their own future
the entire blockchain
invention is innovative
it is creative and until proven
otherwise safe
so i want america and americans just
like yourself i mean you're the one that
wanted to come here
probably we didn't even invite you we
should but you see where there's
opportunity
and that opportunity will lead to
a lifestyle
and an opportunity for you to bring
also the things which you believe are
right now this is where
we kind of got into this earlier about
well is there kind of dangerous that all
these people are coming to texas
coming from california
they're going to have to understand
there's no place after this to move
you just can't embed your government and
give them
the authority or responsibility just to
spend like drunken sailors
you've got to work within the best
interest
of people and so
i i think we're going to do that the
best part about this is
opportunity america needs to own the
future
as we have the past for a long time and
americans
have the creativity the objectivity and
i am
very proud of bitcoin people because
they have come with a balance they care
about
health care they care about disabled
people they care about
uh giving back to their community we
want them to do that with their own
wealth
too
so and so let's focus on bitcoin i
really want to understand what is it
specifically about the technology that
you like and you think would add value
to america
well
it is once again an opportunity for
people to own their own piece of the
rock
it's an opportunity for them to know
that the
they can go online
they can see
the relative value of the the success
of the currency
it is not easy to see that as a matter
of fact we tend to go even though we've
seen some output uh in in the stock
market it is hard to see
the dollar and the dollars what we're
talking about so every time you if you
do want to look up and look at it you
realize it's getting rocked it's we're
taking advantage of it we're borrowing
too much of it it's stability is in
question
there's competition around the world
uh whether we are
creating more wealth or not whether the
government is worried about that soul
factor too
i mean the government is taking
advantage of us the democrats are are
causing our own demise
so
look it's easy to see if you can get a
stable
necessarily a stable system where you
can have better control by looking at it
on your phone
powerful
so there's some concern um
amongst people in this community amongst
bitcoin is that politicians will say
that they're pro bitcoin for votes right
um and this is something that people are
concerned with and we've seen
politicians um i hate to use the term
but it sort of seems the only way to
sort of put it out there sort of come
out as pro bitcoin right um and then
later on
um
say that they are against bitcoin mining
so i don't like to name names but this
is something very concerning that we've
seen mainly from democrat democrat
mayors um so what would you say to
people who may be concerned that perhaps
you know you're just trying to win votes
um what would you say to them to sort of
ease their concerns
well first of all i'm not a democrat
yeah there you go
and it and it is true it is true that
that the other party the socialist party
have been taken over by a large
faction
that many of them actually see what they
believe is the same problem with the
world
and that is
what might be
this
energy issue the uh the chance to to
hate oil companies a chance to want to
go green with everything a chance to
spoil
and and and change what might be
well-established
uh paradigms
uh of of money and opportunity to fear
well we had this one of my problems is i
remember a guy named jimmy carter
jimmy carter
had everybody fear he's a mongerer
we have long lines
uh all across america in the in the
globe and he just fed that to where
you know we not only did we get ronald
reagan but we started learning more
about
are we really running out of energy
are we afraid of our future is there not
something that we can use time and
technology and
and ingenuity
right now today there is more
online we know this
more natural gas than we've ever
had and that's because of not just
discoveries but that is because
of of a demand that we have and so
america is the saudia
saudi arabia of of this
very important
asset net gas natural gas
and yet lots of states and lots of
territories and places they won't go and
even dig into this so
look it's money's going to be made
there's going to be opportunity
we need a clean opportunity we need an
opportunity to have clean energy i'm all
for it uh but we we are headed that way
we're headed that way we're not only
with hydrogen
but other opportunities
and so i feel very bullish
about our ability to have a cleaner
environment moving forward
but not putting us all in bicycles which
is what the democrats want
okay so let's go back to the democrats
we've seen um a video actually of
elizabeth warren um refusing to
understand that bitcoin um is not good
when it comes to um criminal activity um
she was sort of saying you know using
non-custodial wallets um it can
essentially help enable illicit activity
and somebody was trying to explain to
her that actually that's not the case
because so on and so on and so on but
she refused to listen and which was
quite sad and quite shocking actually um
just to refuse to to learn something
well why do you think that is so the
question is why do you think do you
think it do you think it's um
uh an uh perhaps an age thing do you
think it's perhaps um you know done on
purpose why do you think certain people
refuse to understand bitcoin and
therefore take actually um a
anti-bitcoin approach
well i think it's from my perspective
who knows who's right uh that's a
freedom time kind of thing in the
federal government uh when controlled by
democrats and the way democrats operate
they like to control people they want to
control activity they want to control
outcome
uh not unusual but literally every
single bill we have in congress is
either
more taxes more spending more
regulations
or the reverse of that and then you look
up the other person that's behind it ah
it's a republican that wants
more freedom and opportunity see
we know what we do works we know that
that's why there's more money coming in
the federal government than ever
when we cut taxes that's because we
incented people
to go make it work and so
look
god made at least two kinds of people
i want to be for freedom i want to be a
republican i want to live in texas
and they they literally
uh are they think we're absurd here
but
let people make their own decision i
think i know the right answer and i know
where i am
so you're clearly very bullish on
bitcoin where do you see bitcoins um
place in american society
well i see it increasingly over the
future i think the future uh i i i'm for
our country i don't want to see our
demise but you just cannot take on the
tremendous load
of spending that we have and debt and
and you you can't do it your own life
and our country cannot do this and have
a brighter future so
as long as we have democrats that are in
control and whether they're running our
cities or whether they're running our
states or whether they're running our
federal government they will bankrupt us
they will cause inflation to be
outrageously
uh
uh
powerful to where it steals and robs our
future and this is where
if you save money if you put money in
and build on that
you can over time make a difference in
everybody's life
and
there's there's a dark side to this
big spending and democrats are perfectly
happy with it they
the chairman of the house budget
committee argued
that it doesn't matter how much money
you spend or how what you do
it deficits do not harm anyone and he
encouraged it by the way he's not
running for reelection now
but do you see bitcoin as a store of
value do you see it becoming a medium of
exchange do you see um do you see it
becoming the world reserve currency do
you see it replacing the us dollar like
specifically where do you see bitcoin's
role in american society
well i see bitcoin's role in american
society is as a opportunity to watch it
grow and for us to learn i i am not for
replacing the dollar i'm just not
i think there's enough room to build
value to where someone else can have
what they want need also but in the
scheme of things uh bitcoin
as tremendously successful as they are
the the reserves of this country are in
the dollar
they're in the the the backing of not
just the federal government they're in
the backing of business
and so over time over time i i i'm not
going to be a naysayer and say it'll
never happen
but i don't think it's in america's best
interest
to get away from the the dollar being
bullish
as the main currency when we start deb
using other people's currency
we're in trouble
so you see it as a store of value then
as something which could potentially
replace gold
i think it's competitive i think it's
very competitive against gold gold is
that standard bearer that uh
you know is ahead what's seen as a hedge
against inflation but
there are a lot of things that have got
to happen and one of them is this
regulatory scheme that we talk about the
regulatory scheme of what are people
going to think about it what does
government think about it and as as you
know there have been decisions where
uh
bitcoin cannot be used for uh
an ira
you also hear stories about how lots of
employees
want their company to begin giving their
pay check or at least their bonus
uh in bitcoin because that they want to
use that
i think that to say that bitcoin
uh
and it's just truthful unless you've
bought in lately
uh virtually everything you've got is a
capital gain
and when you go to spend money and every
time you produce a probably a vast
amount of taxation
off your use of money
that that's difficult
and so there it as it as time moves on
as it as there's less
necessarily uh
uh
volatility then then it could become but
i think there will be other things that
come in and work uh well with bitcoin uh
cryptocurrency as we know it but
right now
it's very obvious to me
that it it is a it's a high dollar play
it's a i take my bitcoin i go by my uh
sh my chevy tahoe i go buy my
uh big big chevy truck
and i use that that was savings that i
had but uh on a basis of using it to buy
your uh
your lone star beer or to go purchase
what might be uh
your uh your weekly food
that that is going to take a little bit
of time
uh
because you don't want to pay tax on
that
you use it as an investment model as my
point
yeah no i totally understand but it's
been really interesting just hearing
your perspective on bitcoin and you know
how you see how you see it playing out
um especially in times of the
politicization um between you know the
democrats and and the republicans the
unfortunate um
politicization of it i'm on the side we
need to let it grow we need to see what
it can become and
and i i think there's a lot of
exuberance about it
uh
caution yeah sure there's costs there's
caution and put the money in stock
market there's caution about that too
but i i think that that it it finds its
own footing over time
but without any question
entrepreneurship also will build value
uh with goods and services with things
that people do buy and make money with
uh and they'll be in that system
yeah it's been really fascinating so do
you have any final um comments you'd
like to make where can people um you
know follow you support you keep up with
everything that you're doing
yeah i would say that i'm pete sessions
a member of congress from texas the 17th
congressional district
they can look me up and find me
sessions.house.gov
sessions.house.gov
comments i'm on instagram i'm on you
know all this i don't know about all but
the major social media platforms uh if
they'd like to come and engage me if
they told me hey look pete we're
interested in bitcoin
uh and cryptocurrency and i'd please
stay up with us
uh they can go on my website
sessions.house.gov
uh there's a place where they can go and
register themselves and tell me what
they're interested in
we talk about it we study it we're
trying to be
victors for it we want to see it
do the right thing
and and i think over time we're going to
be there
congressman pete sessions thank you so
much i really appreciate your time it's
really important to have that
transparency between
voters electorates and obviously
politicians and particularly when it
comes to these new hot topics so i want
to thank you so much for hanging out
now now this weekend are you going to go
to nikki beach
uh no probably not i prefer to
be by myself
listening to music and zoning out
let me tell you what if you want to be
by yourself nikki beach is not
the place to be mike
has a great place there
but it's your closest 100 friends but it
is a topic of conversation in nikki
beach is a very exciting place for for
young women like you to
to rub elbows with people for better
ideas and let's make america great again
maybe i'll have to check out nikki beach
then i'll let you know how it goes
okay good
all right thanks so much and thank you
everyone for watching if you enjoyed
this episode please don't forget to hit
the subscribe button and we will see you
next week bye bye
[Music]